yes exactly i mean we have seen also i  mean if adidas are still against the top  guns he's relying on karo khan i mean  it's certainly not the not opening he  will be relying in uh in three four  years yeah it's uh it's still temporary  he he probably couldn't catch up with  everything yet  so  yeah and and the game has  wow the i mean wow g4 h4 no h file for  you sir no h6g he's really really trying  not to allow any checks  yeah the h1 book h5  yeah unfortunately it's not very  dramatic yeah no still just  interesting psychologically the position  itself is so well i i really hope that  the game will end soon because yeah it's  i just feel like okay ali  should just focus on his next game and  then forget this as quickly as possible  magnus continues with his policy not to  allow that's it  that's it  nice victory